the quest to quash dissensing viewpoints
continues joe biden unveils his radical
plans as the media praise him to the
skies and republican senators consider
whether to impeach trump
after he leaves office i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
stop putting your online data at risk
stop that get protected at
expressvpn.com
it's a brand new week with brand new
news we'll bring you all of it in one
second first
let me tell you you don't need to spend
as much money as you're spending on your
cell phone bill right now you're
spending hundreds and hundreds of
dollars too much
on your cell phone bill probably because
a lot of those big carriers they'll tell
you that you need
unlimited talk and unlimited text and
unlimited data you don't need unlimited
data that is how they are getting you
here is what you actually need unlimited
talk texts six gigs of data for just 30
bucks a month from my friends over at
puretalk
usa when your family switches to pure
talk from ats verizon or t-mobile it
could save over 800
a year which is a lot of money actually
no gimmicks no fluff out is your bills
that's why puretalk is the top
rated wireless company by consumer
affairs they're on the same network as
one of the big carriers but they are
charging you half
again that's unlimited talk text six
gigs of data for just 30 bucks a month
what happens if you go over
on the data usage they're not even going
to charge you for us you have nothing to
lose grab that mobile phone
dial pound 250 say ben shapiro when you
do you'll save 50
off your first month dial pound 2 5 0
say keyword ben
shapiro pure talk usa is simply smarter
wireless go check them out right now
dial pound 2 5 0 say keyword ben
shapiro pound 250 say keyword ben
shapiro okay so the continuous attempt
by the media
to use the capital right as an excuse to
basically shut down the political
opinion of half the country that is an
ongoing thing it is not going to stop
and it's going to be the story of the
next several years
by the way i said this literally today
other riots the theme of the
of the show the day after the riots was
twofold one
what we just saw was evil it was an
outgrowth
of people believing things that are not
true and buying into a conspiratorial
mindset that was theme number one
theme number two was the left is going
to use this as a baton for the next
several years
in order to club into submission anybody
anybody who opposes any element of their
agenda
see right now there are some republicans
who are receiving quote unquote strange
new respect from the left and these are
people who
very often i like people like senator
ben sasse from nebraska people like liz
chaney from wyoming do you
actually think that democrats for more
than five seconds
are going to appreciate liz cheney and
ben sasse do you think that's going to
happen you think the media
five minutes from now are going to be
talking about the wonders of liz cheney
and ben sasse that's not to say that
what they have been saying or doing is
wrong
it's just to point out that the left is
completely untrustworthy i'm not talking
about
good hearted liberals there are some of
those they exist they are in the
minority when it comes to the democratic
party they are in a
vast minority when it comes to our media
for sure okay the fact is that the
strange new respect being garnered by
some of these republicans will evaporate
literally the moment
their agenda comes into conflict with
the agenda of the left i know this
because i got some of this in 2016 right
in 2016 i didn't vote for either of the
candidates
i said neither one of these people meets
my minimum qualifications to be
president of the united states
and i got a few nice articles from some
of the big newspapers the strange new
respect
and then literally the minute i said oh
yeah and by the way i also like
trump's judicial picks he was like oh
well we always knew that he was a crazy
right winger liking trump's judicial
picks that just shows that he's in
league with fascism
and this is the game that the left loves
to play
you're going to be their friend so long
as they can use you to serve a
particular agenda
and then you are the enemy well right
now the left is going whole hog
full bore in attempting to use what
happened at the capitol right again
an act of nearly unprecedented evil
right it was the second storming
of the american capitol building in
american history like 1812 and now right
so that was a very very ugly
horrifying incident we are very lucky it
didn't get a lot worse because there is
some pretty solid evidence that people
in the building want to do actual
violent harm
to vice president pence to members of
the senate to members of congress
also members of the media members of the
tech
companies members of the democratic
party are seeing this
as just a way to as a pretext frankly
to shut down other alternative sources
of information
we saw this all last week we saw some of
the week before we've been seeing it for
a long time
this goal of the left which was to sort
of chip away
at the at the facade of free speech
until it crumbles well now they're not
just chipping away they've grabbed the
jackhammer and they are just going to
work
everybody who supported trump in any way
is now guilty you're a racist
therefore your rights do not matter as
much as other people who are not racist
meaning they agree with the folks over
at cnn
if you're on facebook if you're on
twitter if you have any following
well you know you are a danger to the
republic because you know what would be
great
unity unity through surrender all you
guys have to do is just surrender
and then we'll have unity again isn't
that an exciting piece of news
and there is no question that this is
the agenda that is going to be pursued
now there are two agendas that are scary
for people who are conservative one
is the sort of legislative agenda of the
democratic party which does run contrary
to american perceptions of rights on
everything from economics to freedom of
speech to freedom of religion
and we'll be talking about all of those
legislative infringements
those executive infringements against
your rights
under the constitution of the united
states but there is something else
that's happening
and that is the continuation the
deepening the broadening
of a social culture of ostracization
marginalization
and quashing of this of descent that is
the
america has always run along two traps
it attracts right one track is the
governmental
and then there's the cultural and when
the culture of the united states
is censorious when the culture of the
united states is one that does not
tolerate dissent when the culture of the
united states
ostracizes particular points of view
very often it is only a moment before
that is actually encoded in legislation
and even without it being encoded in
legislation it can make your life
absolutely miserable
if you're barred from jobs because of
your political point of view if you're
barred
from the media through which you
disseminate information
not media isn't like the press like the
medium plural if you
are if you are barred from the use of
social media for example because
your viewpoints are now considered
dangerous not on the basis of you
actually posing in danger
but on the basis that perhaps some nutty
person could take
your views and then twist them to get to
a particular conclusion and now you can
be blamed for the violence
well the social situation in which you
live is just going to be made worse and
worse the polarization is going to get
wider and wider unity is not going to be
constructed this way
unity is constructed through honest
engagement but what we have right now is
dishonest disengagement
and you can see it the media are pushing
this hard why well two reasons one
they're ideologically driven to do it
because they sense the kill they sense
the kill they believe that the obama
coalition created
in 2012 which was the quote-unquote
coalition of the dispossessed it was
going to be
a group of people who had been
marginalized by american society that
was their coalition
various racial ethnic sexual orientation
groups all cobbled together with
college-educated white women that was
going to be the new democratic coalition
it was the coalition of the ascendant
was going to wipe away
all of the past of america and bring us
into this brighton future it was delayed
by the election of trump
it was delayed by the republicans in
2010 when the republicans won congress
well now they're going to move ahead
full steam right this is the backlash
and it will they will brook no descent
they will brook no discussion
the discussion is over now it's just
time to move
right that is what we are getting so
there's an ideological sense in the
media that now is their moment that was
now is the moment to usher in utopia and
anyone who stands
in the way of utopia is an obstacle
you're either a tool or you're an
obstacle in the leftist pursuit of
utopia in the media that is
number one number two there's an actual
market reason why you want to get rid of
your competitors
see we here at the ben shapiro show and
a daily wire generally
we cut against our own market interest
because we don't like to engage in
either regulatory or cultural capture
what i mean by that is we have never
said that people who disagree with us
should be quote unquote d platformed we
have never claimed that you should not
listen
to pod save america we have never
claimed you should not watch msnbc
we have suggested disagreement with
those people i've said many of those
people i think are idiots but
i've never said that their advertisers
should pull i've never suggested
that podcasts should be pulled from
apple podcast or that people who
who do shows for those outlets should
not be allowed to write for popular
publications
i've never suggested that any of these
places ought to come down
other than when i suggested that maybe
mutually assured destruction has to take
place because the left is aggressing in
this area okay but the left
has a mark now it would be in my market
interest to see all of our competitors
go away
it would right when it comes to you
making money
getting rid of your competitors is very
useful but that's not what we do here at
daily wire we have encouraged people
to go join up with alternative services
not only on the left but on the right
right people who are in our direct space
quote-unquote direct competitors many
times on the show i have told you that
you should go get a subscription
at places that you enjoy right places
that are not us
okay and i thank you for doing that
really we thank our audience because you
make it possible every single day for us
to do
what we do and we couldn't be more
grateful for that as we surge into new
areas
okay but when it comes to the when it
comes to the media again it's twofold
their goal one
ideological dissent must not be brooked
and two
what if we could just wipe away the
competition they didn't exist anymore
wouldn't that be nice
then you wouldn't have to worry about
you know people watching the ben shapiro
show as opposed to cnn daytime
what if they just didn't exist that'd be
great wouldn't it you know you think i'm
exaggerating here that this is not the
agenda
on wide parts of the left again not
everybody on the left
feels this way there are some liberals
who believe in the possibility of having
discussion and dissent and debate but
they are increasingly a minority
inside their own political world view
we'll get to the proof
that this is becoming the mainstream of
the democratic party if it is not
already the mainstream of the democratic
party in
just one second first let us talk about
the fact that this time of year a lot of
people showing up at that front door i
got people delivering groceries you have
packages from online orders that are
arriving
and for me i always have to keep track
of my kids i have three kids under the
age
of seven they're constantly running
around i only have two eyeballs i have
three kids and
my two eyeballs are fixed together so i
can't actually have one eyeball going in
one direction and one
and the other direction like the guy
from young frankenstein that means that
i actually have to have
ring devices around my house so i can
keep track of my children with ring
you can see and speak to whoever is at
your door from anywhere right on your
phone you're never going to miss a
visitor whether it's your neighbor your
dinner your groceries you can keep those
packages and delivery safe with motion
detection you'll get notified even if
they don't ring the doorbell
if someone stops by or something is
going on ring will let you know
i love having that ring video doorbell
i've actually added some ring security
cameras around the house
as well no matter your home ring has
everything you need to protect it
sp see and speak to whoever is at your
door from anywhere with video doorbells
keep an eye on every corner of your
house with easy to install indoor and
outdoor cams protect your whole home
with ring alarm it's a powerful
affordable whole home security system
you can easily install yourself right
now
got a special offer on the ring welcome
kit at ring.com
it comes with that ring video doorbell 3
and the chime pro it's the perfect way
to upgrade your front door start your
ring experience when we moved my wife is
like get the ring devices on the house
one of the first things we did go to
ring.com and do the same that's ring.com
ben for the special offer on the ring
welcome kid again ring.com
ben okay so here is some of the proof
that you are seeing
a widespread movement to silence descent
it's a jack boot with a smiley face on
it
really exciting stuff so don lemon last
week over at cnn
who again builds himself as an objective
news reporter which is just hysterically
funny
like in a very in a very sort of
pessimistic sense it's extremely funny
like a cynically pessimistic sense so
here was uh don lemon
declaring that literally everybody who
voted for donald trump is a racist all
of them
all 74 million people and presumably
members of their family their children
will grow up to be racist so here he is
ostracizing literally half the country
it doesn't mean that a voter believes
that their vote means what you think it
means
well but it also believes it also means
that you share something with that
person and you must own up to it
and you have to we have to stop saying
giving people an out
for the for people who represent the
worst behavior stop trying to make an
excuse
for people who voted for someone who has
those beliefs that you may think that
you don't believe that
but in a way what you're doing you're
complicit with it because you are voting
for the same type of person you see
you're complicit
everything bad a candidate does you're
now complicit in so did you know
that every democrat who is a fan of ted
kennedy was a fan of him drowning a
woman at chappaquiddick
were you aware that every single
democrat who voted for bill clinton in
1996 was totally fine with him banging
women in the oval office using cigars
were you aware of that were you totally
aware that every single person
who voted for joe biden was totally in
favor of the blm riots this summer like
in favor of the riots themselves isn't
that amazing
like the worst things about all
candidates that's the stuff you're
endorsing according to don lemon except
he doesn't apply that logic to anybody
on the left it only applies
to people who are on the right why is
that he can castigate them and ostracize
them and then suggest
that they need to be ousted from
traditional american society
it's funny uh there's a guy who's
actually my lawyer
one of my lawyers kurt schlichter so
kurt is a good dude yeah
served in the u.s army and he's a
lieutenant colonel in the us army
and he had a piece today talking about
maybe what we're going to need on the
right here at the state level is the
anti-discrimination law that applies to
politics
and he makes the point that we now have
a situation in anti-discrimination well
whereas a private actor you're not
allowed to discriminate on the basis of
race sex sexual orientation
religion he says why not on the basis of
politics too because obviously that is
the next
step here we've already moved beyond no
discrimination against immutable
characteristics right it's not about
race it's not about sex anymore now it's
about things like
sexual orientation which is a which is a
behavioral thing or religion which is a
behavioral thing
i said why not do it with politics as
well
and so in any case maybe that's the way
that states are gonna move
is that we're gonna now force private
companies to hire people regardless of
political orientation now i'm a believer
that freedom of association is still a
thing
we shouldn't be doing this on any front
but if the left pushes this that is
going to be
the natural reaction here okay and you
can see the quest is stymie
it is widespread and it is deep and the
media love it the media love it
your denizens the people who are
claiming for the last several years
that freedom of speech and freedom of
the press were under assault in america
right donald trump was going to come to
the offices of cnn and shut them down
their ratings have never been better by
the way
well a former facebook insider named
alex stamos was talking with your most
reliable source brian stelter he is the
most reliable of all the reliable
sources
and his job is to be a media watchdog
which basically means he watches fox
news and then muses about it
and honestly it's really kind of a sad
show anyway brian stelter was talking
with face
with former facebook insider alex stamos
and stamos
says you know what the big problem here
is that there are people who can get
information from places that are not cnn
we need to cut that out
we need big tech companies we need
comcast to stop broadcasting fox news
we need people to to just stop watching
things on youtube
what if youtube just shut those down
they're not being
shy about this guys they're not being
coy okay the attempt here
to to quash the ability socially
speaking and then eventually
governmentally of people i disagree with
to speak
is very real and they're not being
they're not being in any way reticent
they're not wallflowers about this
here's alex damon's former facebook
insider to the nodding of brian stelter
who's supposed to be captain first
amendment over here
we have to turn down the capability of
these conservative influencers
to reach these huge audiences there are
people on youtube for example
that have a larger daytime a larger
audience than daytime cnn
and they are extremely radical in
pushing extremely
uh radical views and so it's up to the
facebooks and youtubes in particular
to think about whether or not they want
to be effectively cable networks for
disinformation
and then we're gonna have to figure out
the oa n and newsmax problem you know
that
these companies have freedom of speech
but i'm not sure we need
verizon at t comcast and such to be
bringing them into
tens of millions of homes right we need
to de-platform all of these places now
here's the thing it sounds nice when
you're talking about people who are
quote-unquote outliers you know these
radicals but who the hell is he talking
about who's he talking about
well maybe he's talking about you know
folks like alex jones but i believe that
alex jones has already pulled off of
youtube
i oppose that at the time by the way not
because i agree with alex jones i think
alex jones is like cooking a nut
but because i don't think that these
folks have any standards whatsoever i
think that their standard
for people who should not be platformed
on youtube is they disagree with me
when he says that newsmax and oann ought
to come down i don't think that he
believes that because oann
and newsmax were saying things that were
not true about dominion voting systems
and the veracity of the last vote i
think that these folks are upset
because newsmax and oa i think they
would apply the same exact logic to fox
news
in fact there are articles over the
weekend exactly applying the same logic
to
what a fox news came down wouldn't that
be nice if we could just create the
media monopoly anew
wouldn't that just be fantastic wouldn't
that be great in every conceivable way
they're not being shy about this gang
they want to shut down the dissemination
of information they want it okay here is
joe scarborough and mika brzezinski who
by the way were chuckling it up
with with donald trump throughout the
2015-2016 race they were besties
scarborough and trump were besties with
testes man they were just on tv
hanging out all day long you know joking
about the other candidates
and they were they were good friends and
there was a rumor that joe scarborough
wanted to run with donald trump in 2016.
now scarborough and mika are saying
things like you know what it's time to
maybe we should like d-platform twitter
and facebook because of the riot
not because they hate tech bros who run
twitter and facebook but because those
are places where you can get alternative
information
so this is the threat the threat is do
what we want or
we will maybe we should just de-platform
you maybe we should get rid of you
i mean if you can't see the threat here
if you can't see the socially fascistic
threat here
i don't know what you're watching i
don't know what country you are living
in if you don't see the socially
fastistic threat that has been
materializing in extraordinarily rapid
fashion
i mean the capital riot was chum in the
water to people
who wanted to shut down freedom of
speech and freedom of descent
those rioters did something horrible and
evil they believed lies they believed
untruths they were cr they were doing
crazy things they are criminals who
should go to jail
it is also true again two things being
true at once that there are a bunch of
people who saw this as an opportunity
and now they've ratcheted up the volume
in dramatic fashion here was mika and
joe talking about
twitter and facebook because facebook's
algorithms were set up to
cause this sort of radicalism to explode
guess what happened their likes exploded
the people following them exploded
so so you actually had facebook
and twitter set up their business models
in a way that would lead to the
insurrection
against the united states of america it
is
on them and here's the best news of all
members of the media they cannot
identify their own bias
you see from where they sit they don't
even understand what i'm saying
it doesn't even compute it doesn't
compute if you say to them guys you know
you at cnn you have a bias and you've
disseminated in
misinformation many many times you spent
four years pushing the russian collusion
nonsense
you you suggested that the covington
catholic kids were a bunch of racists
you used members of the media spent
months declaring that riots were not
riots they were mostly peaceful protests
you spent months declaring that every
death in the united states because of
the covetous because donald trump i mean
like you guys disseminate information
on an extraordinarily regular basis and
sometimes you have to actually pay up in
lawsuits
cnn was sued and they paid a settlement
to the covington catholic kids
and but if you say that to them yeah but
we're different we're totally different
than anybody else because we are
objective
it's not just that they masquerade as
objective it's that they have
they have imbibed into their bones the
lie that they are objective
idea that they hold themselves to a
higher standard
they do not they hold themselves to a
lower standard because in many cases
they are more dishonest they are
extraordinarily dishonest not
in that they are telling overt lies all
the time but in that they lie about
themselves they lie about what they are
and what they
are not if you think that don lemon or
chris cuomo or yes jake tapper that they
don't have political opinions and i like
jake that
they do have political opinions and it
is fairly obvious they have political
opinions they do have audiences and they
do cater to those audiences that's why
they're on the air
and the audiences have political
opinions now last week when there was
this big hubbub about politico because i
wrote the political playbook
world shattering event i got a call from
somebody over at
politico and i was talking with that
person and i said you know the reason
that you're getting this blowback is
because 80 to 90
of your readership is on the left and
they're like no i don't think that's
true it's like then why didn't you get
blowback for chris hayes the day before
well you know chris isn't that controver
chris isn't that controversial
seriously or alternatively you have no
idea what your own audience is
you have such a perverse bizarre
funhouse mirror version of yourself that
you are the only objective voice
in a world of bias it's kind of
self-serving don't you think
okay we'll get to the the complete lack
of self-awareness among members of the
media which allows them to
to push forward with a sensorious social
sphere in just one second first
let us talk about the fact that if
you've got a medical condition and you
haven't gotten it solved that's a
mistake by you you should not be making
that mistake
some medical conditions are you know
weird to talk about difficult to talk
about awkward erectile dysfunction high
on the list well with roman you get a
free online evaluation and ongoing care
for ed all from the comfort and privacy
of your home
a healthcare professional will work with
you to find the best treatment plan if
medication is appropriate roman will
then ship you real medicine with free
two-day shipping the whole process is
straightforward
simple discreet getting started is
really easy just go to getroman.com
complete an online visit
erectile dysfunction used to be tough to
talk about now there is roman complete
that online visit today to connect with
the doctor and get it taken care of
just head on over to getroman.com to get
up to 50 bucks off your first month of
ed treatment
a free online visit free two-day
shipping that's getroman.com for up to
50 bucks off your first month of ed
treatment get roman
dot com slash band that's
g-e-t-r-o-m-a-n-dot-com
you got a medical issue just go get it
solved today get roman.com
ben to get up to 50 bucks off your first
month of ed treatment a free online
visit and
free two-day shipping get getroman.com
ben so here's a perfect example of the
media misunderstanding
their role in the current debate not
understanding their own bias so
h.r mcmaster the former national
security adviser to president trump he
was on cnn
and he was talking about media
polarization he said
you know we have a couple different sets
of media they are catering to completely
different audiences
and mcmaster was talking about media
polarization
and jake tapper responded by saying that
no there's no me
you know it's really only polarization
from one side if you want lies then you
don't come here
hmm yes if you if it's true cnn
is completely down the middle only
people who want the truth go to cnn
i mean honestly i like jake personally
this is so out of touch with reality
here here's hr mcmaster and jake tapper
we have to look at your profession jake
the media you know why is it
that people who lean in one direction
politically watch one cable news station
some who lean in another direction watch
yours or another one
okay i mean the only i don't want to get
into a conversation about cnn
we have a whole show that does that
called reliable sources but i will say
there are channels in which lies are
told and there are channels in which
facts are told and people who want the
lies they don't come here
they go to a different channel um no
actually
people who want a particular point of
view go to cnn and msnbc and people who
want another political point of view go
to fox news or newsmax or oann
and guess what it turns out that members
of the media regardless of point of view
will sometimes disseminate lies
they will they'll run with the story how
many months did we hear that jacob blake
was an unarmed black man shot
his shot nearly to death by police for
no reason other than race
a lot of months right it turned out that
was completely false okay but
again it doesn't matter it's this
perception it's this this self-righteous
perception of the media that allows them
to push forward with the idea that
everybody else should just be shut down
okay and this is extended to the this is
extended to those who are in the
the legislative community so alexander
alcazar cortez who is of course the id
of the democratic party she says what
all the
democrats apparently are thinking but
won't say out loud because it's too
stupid
here's representative alexander
ocasio-cortez d twitch who said that she
has now demanded resignations she's
demanding well
whoop dee what do you frickin do she's
demanding resignations
and i demand her resignation wow is it
working no
that's not how anything works here
anyway here is aoc suggesting
oh sorry i can't call her aoc apparently
it's sexist or something even that's her
twitter handle representative alexander
ocasio-cortez the most honorable of all
congress people
suggesting that it's time to demand
resignations of like everyone she
disagrees with all of them
i have demanded the resignations of
senators
ted cruz senators josh hawley
um majority leader republican majority
or rather republican minority leader in
the house
mccarthy kevin mccarthy
along with with many others
because this is not just about
political opinion or partisanship
this was about the abandonment
of our sworn oath
um yeah when i think somebody who really
shows fealty to the constitution of the
united states it's the person
who believes literally said last week
that congress should quote unquote
reign in the media i feel like that
dry ramen guy like point up to the text
of the constitutional first amendment
literally says congress shall make no
law
but don't worry sh it's all about feel
to the it's not about partisanship you
see
because she's a totally objective source
according to herself the lack of
self-awareness is truly incredible okay
in just a second we're going to continue
with the with the rest of the self-aware
brigade okay so meanwhile
the washington dc attorney general
person named carl racine
he has been attempting to rebut some
arguments to the right so one of the
arguments of the right is you know you
guys are very much against political
violence when it seems to spring from
the trump side
but you weren't so against political
violence when it was springing from your
side of the aisle five minutes ago
the defense apparently from the the
defense apparently from
members of the left is that well
yeah but it's different when our side
does it yes i'm noticing the double
standard here is
washington dc attorney general carl
racine he says you know black lives
matter that's that's different from the
capital riots
when people like general mattis made
clear
that what this was was an attempted
insurrection
into our democratic ways we know quite
easily
that the black lives matter protest was
unbelievably different
and by the way do not let anyone
including ken cuccinelli or other
elected officials
tell you that democratic elected people
did not condemn the violence that
occurred
during the summer protest they always
did they always did it was a week-long
controversy as to whether joe biden was
even going to speak up about it
finally he did took him a while but they
always say kamala harris offered to bail
people she tried to bail people out of
prison who were rioting
bail him out of jail in minnesota okay
but it's different when our side does it
right then
because we're the good side that's
that's the way that all of this works
and the media are declaring that before
there is healing before we come together
around some basic principles like facts
should matter and violence is bad
there needs to be some sort of reckoning
it's always the reckoning it's weird
because there's no reckoning on the
other side when the other side does
something bad there's no reckoning they
were just correct to do it in the first
place so if you said listen
we're not going to have a conversation
about violence and politics until you
guys disown the black lives matter
movement
which has expressed antipathy toward
america's founding and timothy toward
america's principles
until you stop with the nonsense where
you go nice
on rioters because they're on your side
or pretend that antifa is just a
philosophy and there's no threat
whatsoever
before before we get together on that
we're gonna need some of that then it's
like no how dare you
we've all no no but when it comes to the
capital riots then it's like it doesn't
matter how forcefully
you condemn the capital rights it
doesn't matter how forcefully you
condemn the underlying lies
or you say it was not true that the
election was stolen it was not true the
vice president in congress
had the ability to overturn duly
certified state electoral results
doesn't matter
you are on the bad side we have to have
a reckoning and the reckoning is shut up
that's the reckoning there's a piece
today from melody barnes
and carolyn janney maryland melody
barnes is co-director of the democracy
initiative at the university of virginia
janney is the john naw professor of
history of the american civil war at the
university of virginia they have a piece
in the washington post titled in a civil
war accountability must proceed healing
and then they compare this to the civil
war and then they say that this is just
like
when general lee surrendered to ulysses
s grant
and how it was bad that grant paroled
these army and sent them home on the
promise they would not be disturbed by
u.s officials so long as they agreed to
henceforth
obey the law they say with no
consequences for their acts of rebellion
the months after appomattox saw former
confederates regain local and state
control and benedict their purposes
they passed black codes which limited
the freedom of four million newly
emancipated men and women they escalated
violence against both african americans
and white southern
unionists the union might have been
preserved by the war but the mystic
chords of memory which lincoln spoke of
in 1861 had yet to bind the hearts and
souls of confederates to their former
enemies
black and white so first of all why are
you in why in the world
are you comparing like normal
republicans to confederates
i have a feeling that that might be one
of the obstacles here we're no
who are the people out there who are
calling for the capital riders not to go
to jail
is there any widespread oppositions the
capital riders going to jail i missed
that part
but say these columnists far from
co-partners in a healing process
those who rampage through the us capital
and others who are at home cheering them
on
have expressed a commitment to continued
violence and upending the rule of law
again this is such a straw man
who in america was cheering on the
capital rioters in any large numbers
who before reconciliation can take hold
say these columnists we must be clear
about who we want to be as a nation and
act on values that support the practice
of democracy
we must also use our constitutional laws
and norms to defeat those who don't
support them the lesson that must be
learned from the civil war and
reconstruction is that accountability
not denial is essential to healing yes
but who is calling for
non-accountability for people who rioted
and the answer is virtually nobody
and yet for some odd reason for some
weird odd
strange reason it seems like they are
claiming that tens of millions of
americans are in favor of what happened
at the capitol riots
and then there is the deeper perspective
from christina beltran she's an
associate professor of social and
cultural analysis at new york university
again a member of our
elite ruling class she had a piece over
the weekend in washington post
saying to understand trump's support we
must think in terms of multiracial
whiteness so she's trying to
understand how many people in the latino
community voted for donald trump and how
many members of black community voted
for donald trump her answer is they're
actually white
because black whiteness is a serious
problem it sounds like an oxymoron to
you but actu
apparently according to this professor
it's a real thing
what are we to make of of the leader of
the proud boys who is
of latino descent and more broadly of
latino voters inspired by trump
what are we to make of an unmistakably
white mob violence that also includes
non-white participants i call this
phenomenon multi-racial whiteness
the promise that they too can lay claim
to the politics of aggression exclusion
and domination good stuff here
right so basically anybody who voted for
trump and is not white just
they're they're still white they just
don't know they're white but don't worry
this is bringing the country together
you see
it's all bringing the country together
because if you can claim white supremacy
lies at the root of your opposition well
then you can just ignore them and you
can exercise them from american
public life speaking of which today
there's a piece in the washington post
from kevin blackistone
kevin blackistone most famously
suggested back in 2013
that the national anthem of the united
states was political and shouldn't be
played at basketball games
because or football games because it was
a war anthem right he said on espn was a
war anthem
nothing happened to him now he is
suggesting of course that kelly lefler
the the defeated soon-to-be former
georgia senator
who owns the atlanta dream which is a
wnba franchise
that she should be forced out of the
wnba forced out of it
because she was thinking of challenging
the electoral votes
in congress but then decided not to so
for that she should be forced out of her
position
okay this is how it's going to go guys
people are going to be forced out of
public life the media
are into it the media love it this is
what they want
they are desperate for it and then
people wonder why the country is so
divided
the country is so divided because you
have one half of the country that would
like to exercise the other half of the
country
that does tend to create a few divisions
and you can see this in the polling
there's a brand new washington post poll
okay and
it's all about the incoming biden
administration it says
that only 49 of americans have a great
deal or a good amount
of confidence that joe biden will make
the right decisions for the country's
future
that would be 89 of democrats of course
but only 43 of independents and 12
percent of republicans so nobody is
actually all that confident
in joe biden beyond that when it comes
to things like
race only 51 percent of americans
believe that they have a good deal of
confidence or
any confidence in um in joe biden to
address unequal treatment because of
race
only 50 of americans believe that joe
biden is going to improve america's
standing in the world
less than half of americans believe that
he's going to rebuild the economy
and like the the polarization here is
pretty extreme and the reason the
polarization is pretty extreme
is because there is actually no attempt
to understand anybody on the other side
of the aisle there's only an attempt to
excise everybody
on the other side of the aisle and the
media cheering it on
cheering it on you want to know i talk
about the media a lot but the media is
the chief method by which you get your
information
okay it's like if somebody has a vision
problem and it turns out
that no matter what they see it is
always in a particular shade
you might say oh maybe it's the glasses
you're wearing maybe it's the media are
the glasses the american public wears
if those glasses happen to be tinted a
particular shade
every a particular shade of blue
everything is going to be viewed throw
those through those spectacles and if
somebody ever says hey you might want to
try this other pair of glasses
and then the members of the media are
like no you can't try those other pair
of glasses those other pair of glasses
make you into terrorists
yes that may have something to do with
our common polarization by the way the
media
the media monopoly that they are
attempting to set up here through social
pressure against the big tech
companies ongoing through social
pressure against you
through social pressure against your
employers what does it result in does it
result
in the kind of balance and objectivity
that they proclaim it's going to result
in
i will show you some pretty hardcore
evidence then no all they want to do is
just establish
a monopoly on your informational sources
while providing you with democratic
propaganda it is obvious
every single day and people always said
that you know trump he was unique he
attacked the press
no folks on my side of the aisle my
parents canceled the la times in the mid
90s because of the bias of the la times
this is a long problem and media's
decision to become a tool of one
political party as opposed to the other
is one of the greatest exacerbating
factors in the conflict that that
is that is ripping apart american
everyday life we'll get to more of this
in just one second first
let us talk about the fact that right
now you probably have a balance on your
credit cards and it has a higher
interest rate than you would prefer
an easy easy way to get in serious loads
of debt is to take out
a loan on the credit card and then not
pay it back because pretty soon they'll
start racking up
exorbitant charges if you're thinking
about the high interest rate credit
cards you used over the holiday
it's time to refinance those credit
cards only lightstream
was ranked number one by jd power for
customer satisfaction with personal
loans
light streams credit card consolidation
loans they start at just 5.95 percent
apr with auto pay and excellent credit
it could save thousands in interest
you can even get your money as soon as
the day you apply apply today for a
credit card consolidation loan from the
company jd power
ranked number one for customer
satisfaction in personal loans plus you
get an additional interest rate discount
at lightstream.com
your bureau that is
l-i-g-h-t-s-t-r-e-a-m.com
shapiro subject to credit approval rates
range from 5.95
apr to 19.99 apr include 0.50
to autopay discount lowest rate requires
excellent credit terms and conditions
apply officers are subject to change
without notice visit lightstream.com
shapiro for more information okay in
just a second
we are going to get back to the proof
that the media who are attempting to
establish a monopoly on your ability to
see information
uh that they are a little biased just a
little
just a little that their perception of
themselves is not accurate first let me
remind you last thursday was an awesome
day for daily why we made our first
entrance into entertainment con
content with our first feature film run
hide fight it is awesome it is an
awesome movie you wonder how awesome the
movie is head on over to rotten tomatoes
because what we do here at daily wire is
we make stuff you love and the critics
hate
that's what we do because if the critics
hate it there's a good shot that you're
gonna huff it
okay at least from our perspective right
now the rotten tomatoes rating from the
critics on run hide fight
is like 14 the audience rating is 97
positive why because the movie kicks ass
it's really great okay the movie is
an excellent thriller it has the values
that you like
it promotes heroism it derides villainy
it's exciting
it is not a preachy movie it is just a
good movie if you missed it head on over
to daily wire you can stream it on
demand from our website mobile or
streaming apps on apple tv and roku
if you aren't a member yet use promo
code rhf for run hide fight rhf to get
off that is rhf and you get 25 off your
membership
now as i mentioned it is not a political
movie it is just an awesome movie
it's about a 17 year old girl who is
fighting her way against
school shooters it's great and we picked
up the movie after hollywood refused to
the critics again gave it a low rating
we know that it's awesome because our
audience loves it 97 98
over rotten tomatoes so if that's you if
you saw the movie and despite what the
left thought would happen actually you
have something good to say about it
please i want you to share it with the
world head on over to rotten tomatoes
and write a review online
it's time conservatives opinion are
heard in the world of entertainment this
is just our first step toward doing that
we have other stuff in the pipeline it's
going to be awesome
we are excited to bring you great
stories hollywood refuses to tell we
hope you'll join us become a member
today over at dailywire.com remember
you'll get 25
off when you use promo code rhf so head
on over to dailywire.com become a member
watch the movie use the promo code rhf
for 25 off this is the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show
in the nation
[Music]
hey so that new that new wonderful clean
and pure dissemination of information
the organs of our media the ones that
you trust right have you
you go there for facts that's all
they'll give you is facts right it's not
that they're trying to set up a
propaganda monopoly on behalf of their
own ideological point of view and by the
way it also helps their pocketbook
it couldn't be that it couldn't be that
i know how objective our media are
because i watched a cbs sunday interview
with kamala harris by jane pauley
okay like and and i will tell you this
is interviewing the likes of which
i have not seen since i don't know like
somebody in in the soviet union bootleg
stalin
like i mean this is this is really this
is really solid stuff right here this is
this is the kind of hard-hitting
journalism
you are going to be getting for the next
four years and everybody who doesn't
believe this is hard-hitting journalism
it's probably misinformation that
they're saying it's not hard-hitting
journalism so
kamala harris who is one of the most
phony politicians i have ever seen in my
life it's like hillary clinton
got more phony and kamala harris is as
purely artificial
as any character i have seen in american
politics right or left
and whenever she gets into an awkward
situation she breaks into the crazy
joker laugh
the media realized how phony she was
back in january of 2020 when she dropped
out of the race they're like oh yeah
yeah she was really a terrible candidate
and then they have to manufacture
enthusiasm for her by the way they're
not doing her any favors because
eventually when she runs for president
they'll have set up a bubble around her
the problem is when the media set up a
bubble around her presuming they haven't
actually shut down all the alternatives
somebody will prick that bubble and then
the entire bubble collapses that's what
happened to hillary they protected her
as though she was the precious for years
and years and years and then donald
trump was like she's terrible i was like
oh my god she is terrible and she just
collapsed
okay well kamal harris is an awful awful
candidate she's a bad politician
she's venal she is she is off-putting
okay everybody knows this everybody knew
this she dropped out of the democratic
primaries again
after having lied about joe biden being
a racist and then having suggested maybe
joe biden should drop out because joe
biden was a sexual harasser
if she did all of those things i know
we're gonna pretend that didn't happen
that all happened
and then she dropped down i never was
like yeah she was really bad then biden
plucked her from semi-obscurity and was
like hey a black woman
i need for my kid my that's what i need
a black lady so
here she is and then like oh my god
she's unbelievable where did you come up
with come
she was there five seconds ago she was
there like literally five seconds ago
she was right there and you were like
she's terrible and then joe biden was
like thing and also
oh she's wow she wears converse guys
like she she's so real she wears
converse
only real people wear converse i mean if
she if she wore like you know fancy
fancy you know if you're fancy shoes
like th then then that would also be
awesome but she wears converse which
means she's a real person okay so
here was kamala she did an interview
with uh jane polly i remember this kind
of
uh just absolutely sycophantic treatment
mike pence receiving this i remember
this i remember the softball interviews
with mike pence
where they talked about what a wonderful
man mike pence was and his tremendous
family life oh wait that never happened
ever not for a single iota of time here
was jane polly interviewing
kamala harris you you have to subscribe
to daily wire honestly so you can see
clips like this
because it doesn't do it justice for you
to hear clips like this
you need to subscribe so you can see
visibly clips like this because jane
polly's reaction is is everything here
it's not kamala harris in this like
kamal harris is just as phony and awful
as she always is
it is jane paulie's reaction to this
clip that is
just it's just astonishing it's
astonishing it's everything
here is uh kamala harris being
interviewed by the very objective
journalist jane polly over at cbs
cbs sunday i was raised to understand
many people will tell you it is
impossible
but don't listen i mentor a lot of
people and i tell them
that there will be people who will say
it's not your turn it's not your time no
one like you has done it
and i'll tell them and don't you listen
and then i will go on to tell them i
eat no for breakfast
what is that what in the world is that
so kamala harris breaks into that crazy
joker cackle
right because that's that's her only li
i don't know what's going on with her
but she she like is constantly breaking
into this weird like she starts the
sentence with laughter and then she ends
the sentence with laughter
and it's not funny so you mostly get the
impression that she has somehow
been dumped into a vat of the joker's
laughing
acid right that weirdly makes you laugh
for no apparent reason
okay so she does that and what does jane
polly do she starts mirroring it
she starts mirroring it right the
expression i'm gonna describe it to you
because
if you can't see it you should have it
described to you her reaction is
that she goes into an enormous enormous
open-mouthed
astonished smile increasing in
enthusiasm
and craziness it's wild it's why i play
it again because it's insane
what is that what is that okay i'll tell
you what that is that's your entire
media when faced with the democrat
that's your entire media that is the
face of your media capture it
put it on your wall that is the face of
the entire media anytime a democrat is
elected when it was barack obama that
was the media's
face when it's kamala harris that is the
media's phase when it's joe biden
that is the media's face but these are
the people who are super objective
they are your guides don't you see they
will tell you when dissemination of
information is improper they will shut
down facebook and twitter because
god forbid shows like this one should
have greater ratings than the
midday crap they put on at cnn that is
the face
of your media jane polly face of the
media give her an emmy
right there that is it that is the face
of your media
forever okay your well lie
the orwell line is that the future of
america is the
is a the future of western civilization
under dictatorship
would be a boot stamped on the human
face forever the future of your media is
that
jane polly faced forever for all time
right that is the because that
those those are your truth tellers those
right there those are your truth tellers
and it's not just jane paulie of course
i'm i'm
suggesting she's representative of the
media because she is representative of
the media when faced with kamala harris
who has now been deemed wondrous
somebody came into the studio this
morning like all my friends love kamala
harris no they don't
no they don't they've been told they
should love kamala harris
nobody in american politics if she if
people liked her kamal harris she would
have scored more than zero
in the democratic primaries zero
i was like no you've just been convinced
because they're gonna have like they had
a full controversy for a week
over the vogue cover of kamala harris
which was supposedly disrespectful
because she was wearing converse which
she does okay
amazing okay but i i don't stop there
when i when i bring you
stories of the media's bootlicking
slavishness
to to the democratic party how about
this one this is from the religion
section over at the washington post
okay remember not an op-ed it's from the
religion section joe biden's catholicism
is all about healing
now he will lead a suffering america
did castro's press do any better than
this
like hugo chavez's press it was like
just like that joe biden's catholicism
is all about healing
is it though he's been denied communion
on the basis
of his unwillingness to support pro-life
views
okay his catholicism it's all about
healing he's like the pope
he's like the woke pope it's really
exciting now he will lead
a suffering america i can't wait for joe
biden to grant me some catholic
absolution i just i can't wait for it
i'm honestly i'm super excited about it
because when i think of just a brand of
catholicism that heals america it's
definitely the brand of catholicism
that says that we should let boys into
girls locker rooms that we should shut
down religious freedom on the basis
of quote unquote transgender rights and
that we should ensure
that abortion is made available to as
many people as humanly possible that
sounds like super catholic stuff to me
this is in the religion section
religion section of the washington post
pitching himself as president joe biden
promised to heal america's hurting soul
his experiences with suffering and
healing were well known including the
deaths of his wife and two children
his struggle against stuttering many
political losses on a bigger stage than
ever biden was trying to show the
country how he did it
through his catholic faith now
biden will lead a nation deeply in need
of healing with soaring coronavirus
cases thousands dying daily millions out
of work hunkered down in isolation he is
not facing one america but two
each claiming with new religious fervor
that god and righteousness are on
its side as divided as any are biden's
own people u.s catholics with millions
don't even see him as a legitimate
catholic at all because of his support
for abortion access and lgbtq
equality the question is how the country
will adjust to a man whose faith doesn't
feature literal bible
bible waving promises to save
christianity or threats that political
opponents might eliminate god
biden presents a less common image a
devout church-going liberal
the country will soon observe for the
first time a president who goes to mass
every sunday
plus on catholic feast days and
sprinkles conversation casually with
scripture
religious hymns references to religious
history but describes faith's purpose
in general inclusive terms as sustenance
for the weary encouragement for the
suffering
and obligation to welcome and care for
one another wow i mean that sounds
controversial to me
wow i can't why would anybody disagree
with joe biden i mean the man's
obviously in favor of every good thing
and against all the bad things
and his catholicism is super duper
pooper scoop reunifying
so that's exciting meanwhile as if that
uh pathetic interview from jane polly
wasn't enough
jessica bennett over the new york times
has a piece today called kamala harris
will make history
so will her big blended family step kids
nieces a doting husband his ex-wife what
the harris m hofs can show
the country um
remember that time when the media
decided that mike pence was a very very
bad man because he's married to one
woman for his entire life
and not only has been married to one
woman his entire life he asks for
permission before he goes
out one-on-one with women from the
office because he wants to respect her
remember that that was a national
controversy
well kamala harris's family is now fair
game but only insofar
as they are just the most wondrous of
all the wondrous people so much wonder
so much
guys if you view anything that is not
this you must
you're engaging in wrong think and you
must stop that you must stop that
immediately now
what is all of this in service of what
is all of this in service of
is it going to be in service of a
moderate agenda an agenda that brings
america together because that's what
i've been informed right is that he's
bringing america together
with faith because when i think of faith
leaders i think of joe biden
hmm okay but he's going to bring us all
together but he shouldn't bring us all
together with like actual you know
moderate policy where we kind of
reach some sort of consensus he should
bring us together by cramming again all
of this is about the cram down
all of this is about a monolithic media
propagandizing on behalf of joe biden so
he can cram down radical policy
that's what this is it it is rife
throughout his administration
on every issue on virtually every issue
he's not going to be standing up to the
radical left he's just gonna be
mainstreaming the radical left that's
all he's gonna be doing
we all know this this is not a secret
okay joe biden
is is a political phony he has been a
political phony his entire life there's
nothing new about this he's been in
congress since he was 30 years old he
was actually too young to serve in the
senate when he was elected
he's been in congress since he was now
seven years younger than i am
he's been living on the public toll that
long he's a lifelong politician
but he is a man of moderation and
principle or alternatively he's just a
tool for whatever the prevailing
ideology of his party is that day
and the pervading prevailing ideology of
his party is radical leftism
okay uh just going to take one example
really fast here is joe biden's deputy
science policy chief talking about
covenant 19.
so proven 19 should be the least
political element of all of american
life
heal the sick make sure those are most
vulnerable get the vaccine instead
it becomes innately political here was
alandra nelson the social science
research council president for princeton
university
social science chair social science
chair not hard science chair social
science social sciences like
where they where they do these studies
that either confirm what you already
knew or are badly flawed
here is uh alandra nelson suggesting the
what we need to do about covet 19.
perhaps never before in living memory
have the connections between our
scientific world and our social world
been quite so stark as they are today
the kovid 19 crisis has inflicted
extraordinary suffering
but it has also held up a mirror to our
society
reflecting in its deadly wake resource
gaps and medical disparities
the inequality we've allowed to calcify
ah there we go
so again every single element of
american life
is going to be geared toward the utopian
agenda it's not about moderation
it's about shut up that's the next
battle that's that's been the battle all
along here by the way
that is the next battle alrighty we will
be back here later today with an
additional hour of the ben shapiro show
coming up soon the matt wells show
airing at 1 30 pm eastern be sure to
check it out i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling production
manager pavel wydowsky
our associate producers are rebecca
doyle and savannah dominguez the show is
edited by adam sciavitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica crams the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright 2021.
on the matt well show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country
not just politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show